we're getting brand new information and
a tragic mistake rocking hollywood alec
baldwin accidentally shooting dead
cinematographer
helena hutchins and wounding the
director after firing off a shot from a
prop gun on the set of his movie in new
mexico
the actor seen crying right after the
incident with witnesses saying baldwin
was asking people around him why he was
handed a hot gun
everybody now wondering how this could
have happened a prop masters union
reportedly saying there was a live round
in the gun baldwin fired and the la
times reported the prop gun misfired
just days before the accident and the
camera crew had previously walked off
the set over unsafe working conditions
the actor tweeting at a statement saying
there are no words to convey a shock and
sadness regarding the tragic accident
and that his heart is broken for the
family of hutchins
baldwin was questioned by police and
released without any charges being filed
and the santa fe sheriff's office says
the investigation remains open and
active and witnesses are being
interviewed
greg this is a crazy story obviously a
lot of protocols were not
followed to have something like this
happen
there's going to be a
huge investigation and potential
mammoth
insurance payout afterwards yeah i mean
he's not just the actor in this he's the
producer so he's got a lot on the line
here
there's
right now i'm going through good greg
bad greg
take your time yes good good greg say
that but i've never heard of good greg
good greg says and good greg feels this
that i feel absolutely awful for the
victim's family i feel absolutely awful
for alec baldwin i can't imagine how
horrible he must feel in that situation
for that to happen it's got to be like
nothing he'll be known for this for the
rest of his life it's horrifying
but then bad greg says
if any one of us had accidentally shot
and killed someone or a police officer
he would be all over it he would show no
such compassion and we know that as a
gun control activist that he's done that
to to police officers online um he would
destroy us so that's bad greg
so good greg is going to say
okay this is about training this is
about violating the golden rules of
handling guns you know one you always
point it in the safe direction and
number two your finger is always off the
trigger and this all goes even in movies
and you always keep the gun unloaded
until you use it and all and treat all
guns as though they are loaded that's
what i learned from my nra training from
mark centrillo my trainer i learned
those things and as a neurotic i am a
very very good gun owner
so
what might have caused this carelessness
and probably comfort in the sense that
you're in this land of make-believe so
you forget the protocols it's a really
interesting hypocrisy in hollywood
there's a lack of respect for guns by
the characters that the actors are
playing right there's never any recoil
they're always pointing the gun like
this
this is not a real realistic gun
practices so the hypocrisy is
people in movies propagate unsafe gun
practices while condemning the nra which
pushes safe gun practices so you have
this evil this the evil prison of two
ideas you're either pro-gun control
or you're evil and that prevents you
from benefiting from your adversary's
training training from your sworn enemy
the nra
would have prevented this if you had
actual nra training this would not have
happened but i doubt alec baldwin had
any nra training having said that i feel
awful feel awful about it
what does good kennedy and bad kennedy
have to say about this um i i share uh
greg's remorse for this i i feel really
bad for that woman's family because you
know she's going to work
she's a real badass a woman in a very
male dominated profession director of
photography uh with a son and a husband
you think you know it's going to be safe
you're going on location uh it's pretty
rotes and then she loses her life uh
that's you know good kennedy i'm really
just piggybacking on good greg because
it's friday and piggybacking is fun um
but uh bad kennedy asks
who killed this woman did the gun kill
this woman or did alec baldwin that's
interesting killed this woman and i
think that ultimately uh will be the
question when the lawsuits are filed who
is responsible here and it's very
interesting i know degan can speak to
this in greater detail but i think this
is going to be part of a huge union
fight because the unions are going to
say if you had more union involvement
this would be safer unions make
everything better uh we know that is not
necessarily the case especially for
things like teachers unions and every
other public sector union
but i think that is going to be the
thrust of a massive fight aside from the
questions that are directly asked of
this case yeah they're going to have to
find out were well-trained
well-organized union members responsible
for
handling this weapon appropriately and
then did they leave or were they fired
did they walk off the set because of
this brouhaha over cost cutting and
with all this
stuff not there
did a mistake happen
well the l.a times is reporting that the
camera crew members of the international
alliance of theatrical stage employees
iatsi
spent they walked off the set and it
appears as if there were certainly
non-union workers
filling in so again were the standard
safety protocols being followed by the
prop master the armorer the stunt
coordinator and the like but ayatse that
union is already in a huge contract
fight with the studios so it does raise
the attention and level
of
outrage based on those union members
about what's going on but it's speaking
of gun control when these horrible
accidents happen i always wake up
and think who's going to weigh in on
social media for their own benefit for
attention to bloat their own ego to feed
their own narcissism and guess who it
was today gun control advocates they hit
the twitt sphere almost immediately
trying to exploit this tragedy for
again for their own agenda
this is a workplace accident
and none of their ideas on restricting
gun ownership or dismantling abolishing
the second amendment would prevent this
tragic accident from happening it's
negligence clear
based on what we know it looks like
negligence but this just seemed gross
and it's not going to change anybody's
mind about gun control but here's just
one example of what i saw francis fisher
is one of the stars on this movie yeah
and she had she retweeted this tweet
from shannon watts of mom's demand
it's saying
these what you're saying in this tweet
she was quoting a daily beast article
and francis fisher said these quotes are
inaccurate our director's already out of
the hospital
she had said he was in intensive care i
don't subscribe to the daily beast so if
that's what they're saying they're wrong
can you correct them but again it's this
rush to make this
accident this death about
gun control and it just raises the issue
of like
whatever happened to having some grace
and just shutting hell up if you're not
going to say thoughts and prayers then
don't say anything something that's
roundly mocked by the left often jessica
well there were some very unpalatable
tweets from both sides jd vance who is
running for senator ohio tweeted
something absolutely disgusting about
letting trump back on so you know alec
baldwin who famously played him on snl
we can have more tweets congresswoman
lauren beaubert also tweeted something
disgusting it's definitely not a time
for any of that especially because this
was a workplace accident
i'm curious to see what alec baldwin's
role as a producer on this does in terms
of complicating the situation for him
and i grew up going to movie sets a lot
my dad was a producer and
i noticed even from the age of seven
when i was kind of becoming cognizant of
what was going on how nervous the actors
were around guns to make sure that
everything was going to be fine because
they aren't firearms experts they are
not people who have had training in this
and you rely on the people whether it's
the union folks or the private handlers
that have been hired to ensure that it
is going to be safe and this idea of
that there were real bullets in there
and i understand that that can happen
before and i think it was brandon lee
was the last time someone died on a set
in 1993.
the crow wasn't that still a i mean the
blank comes out at the same speed
but it doesn't he died in surgery yeah
he died after six hours of surgery but
what happened was there was a squib in
the gun which is meant to look like a
real bullet but it doesn't it um has the
powder removed from it and there was a
fragment from the squib that was in
uh in the um in the gun and then they
used a blank which is a full charge no
lead so the blank the charge sent that
projectile out of the gun and killed him
ultimately all right horrible tragedy
sorry to continue to keep you guys
posted as we find out more information
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else